[Music]
high above our heads is the
International Space Station it's an
amazing complex thing the most
complicated thing we've ever built in
space one of the most complex
international projects ever conceived
and ever completed but the key word out
of that is International it is a place
built by people from all around the
planet 15 different countries and that
just sounds sort of theoretical until
you start thinking different languages
different units measurement systems you
know is it inches or is it meters
different electrical systems is is it
220 is it 110 is it positive ground is
it negative ground but the most complex
problem to deal with often is just
people who have come from a wildly
different cultural background a
completely different sense of what is
normal what what are you doing a Friday
night
what does yes mean what does uh-huh mean
you know what is the day of worship what
when do you celebrate a holiday how do
you treat your spouse your children how
do you treat each other what is the
hierarchy of command all of those things
seem completely clear to you but you
were raised in a specific culture that
is actually shared by no one else
they're just if you have brothers or
sisters have asked your brother and
sister in detail about some stuff and
they will disagree with you they have a
different culture than you do
so imagine if the people that you're
flying a spaceship with come from a
wildly different part of the world the
trying to find a way to share a sense of
purpose so that you can overcome the
natural barriers of a difference of
culture to do something really difficult
that's one of the biggest tasks that an
astronaut faces you can start just by
learning language it's obvious if it's
if it's as discrete as learning English
or learning Russian or learning Japanese
that that's a clearly defined language
but have someone from Louisiana talked
to someone from Brooklyn they both speak
English but the language is very
different
if you want to speak clearly and
communicate with that person you have to
recognize that that the culture with
which they interpret the world is
absolutely necessary for you to
understand if you want to clearly
communicate with them and for me the
only real measure of clear communication
and successful communication is a change
of behavior of the listener if all they
did was go uh-huh then you have no
understanding of whether they actually
comprehended and internalized what it
was you were trying to communicate to
them but if you can see that their
actions now reflect a different idea and
then you can measure whether what you
were intending actually got communicated
across then the loop is complete and
you've successfully crossed whatever
cultural barrier was there and so that
requires a lot of extra effort learning
to speak the language learning to
express yourself in a way that is
meaningful to the person you're talking
to and then doing it on a frequent
enough basis to be able to see that your
message got through and see that that
person is doing what it was that you
were talking to them about seeing a
change of behavior so that you know for
sure that the two of you are on the same
page of this new thing that you're doing
it's complex it's not natural it's
difficult but it's necessary and the
higher the stakes are if you're doing
something that is life or death or doing
something that has big financial
consequence then the necessity to
communicate effectively and clearly just
continues to skyrocket continues to go
up and it really puts more pressure on
your own shoulders to learn to be a good
communicator but also learn to be as
sensitive and aware as you possibly can
of the people that you're speaking with
try and overcome all of those natural
barriers try and accomplish something
together no matter where you're from
[Music]